hey guys it's Maddy so I've got a brand
new lipstick
Very Berry from my new line makeup by
Maddie follow the natural shape you live
this color is a bright people will give
you that extra pop get the right brush i
stuff this all over the place strangled
and doesn't look like the old girl went
down easy
the detectives always tell me pj don't
solve the cases just examine the bodies
BJ don't touch that that's sensitive
everything's Peter did you eat my
lasagna yes Bernard yes I love lasagna
and I just can't help but wonder what
happens to some of these poor folks hey
looky that that is definitely a stamp
from the Leila lounge I have lost a lot
of my dignity there
[Music]
Tess I'm dying over that lip color
oh thanks Mads I actually designed it
myself
very very you have your own line I am
making a million selling eggs I actually
hurt my wrist counting all that I'm
kidding I heard it at the gym look a man
sure keep me to escape
oh no no no I know I'm getting this one
thank you
I love that lip color on you oh he's the
martinis they'll ketchup and then the
music garbage not for me
what are you gonna do let's take a look
shall we hmm
nice color
[Music]
hey Maddie
don't forget read tonight oh crap this
is the fourth month in a row I can't
keep covering for you do you know I
skipped class four times to pick up
extra hours at work do you want some
free product you could use it no you
used to be nice it was a joke Morgan I'm
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
okay bruising strangulation
the assailant must have used some sort
of strap oh maybe a jealous lover
perhaps mm the French accent I love it
hmm sorry I just have to check comments
I know okay what dude I'm tired I'm
tired of you treating me like this dude
and working that's all that you ever do
you know I need your time to kind of
baby and if not your mom's just grow up
these fans of yours they're not gonna be
around forever when they're gone I hope
you still have the sound of your own
voice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
ah
any kind of done such a thing
[Music]
was it Regan the jealous boyfriend Tess
the friend from whom Matty stole or
Morgan the frustrate room are you going
somewhere just to the bar so you have
money for that no but I do have friends
unlike some people
[Music]
until you how to properly
[Music]
[Music]
sorry for what happened to you Maddie
[Music]
Oh
Oh